-Our next guest is a talented
actor who you can see in
the new series "The Afterparty,"
which premieres this Friday
on Apple TV+.
Please welcome Dave Franco!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's what I'm talking about.
Yes!
Dave, thank you
for being here, buddy.
I really appreciate this.
-Of course.
Thank you for having me.
-Last time you were here,
we talked about your cats.
So I should just ask, just to be
polite, how are your cats?
-Yeah, that checks out.
I actually did another interview
recently where
the journalist asked,
"What defines you?
You know, What do most people
associate you with?"
And I was like, "Wow,
that's a really good question."
And all of my castmates chimed
in, and they were like, "Cats."
And I was like, "Wow,
I guess that is sadly true."
But for whatever reason,
at some point,
being obsessed with cats became,
like, a quirky character trait.
Like, why is loving cats
not the norm?
-Wow. I mean, do you really --
It is, I mean, kind of the norm.
I mean, some people
are dog people, I guess,
but some people are --
You know, I --
-Everyone's dog people.
If you look at
all popular culture,
anytime there's a cat onscreen,
they're the bad guy.
What's up with that?
And so, like,
within our household,
we treat our two cats
like little gods.
And we've actually gotten to
the point where
we start having back-and-forth
conversations with them.
We are -- We have
turned into those people.
-Wow. We actually have
a video of
Dave Franco in conversation
with his cat, Otis.
This is real. Take a look.
-Odie.
[ Cat meows ]
Otis.
O-Boy.
[ Cat meows ]
-Wow! I've never seen anyone
do that in my life.
-Hey, I've heard
all this stuff about
Chris Evans' dog being famous.
I'm just trying to get my boy
Otis up there with him.
-That's what
I'm talking about, Otis.
Let's get Otis a movie.
Let's get Otis a voiceover.
At least a voiceover
in a cartoon.
-Absolutely.
-I want to talk about
"The Afterparty."
It premieres this Friday
on Apple TV+.
Man, is it funny.
And it's from
the same team that did
"21 Jump Street"
and the "Lego" movies.
If you guys saw any of
the "Lego" movies.
-Yeah.
-They're brilliant.
It is such a -- They're such
great writers, producers,
directors.
But can you set up what
"The Afterparty" is all about?
-Yes, so, it's a murder mystery
set at a high-school reunion,
where each episode is told from
a different character's
point of view.
And the character's personality
actually informs
the genre of each episode.
So, like, the jocks episode
is shot like an action movie,
and the art-students episode
is actually animated.
And so on and so on.
So it's, like,
a very, very unique concept.
-You play a famous
pop singer named Xavier.
-Correct.
-Great name, by the way.
And you have a great look.
I guess we do have
a picture of it.
Here's Xavier here.
Yeah. Now, Xavier had to --
You had to record some
original pop songs.
Do you get nervous when
you have to sing or no,
you're like, "Oh, I can do it"?
-No, I'm not very proficient
when it comes to singing.
This was my first time,
like, doing it "professionally,"
and it was very scary.
I mean, not just the singing,
but the actual songs.
You know, titles like
"X Marks the G-Spot"
and "Do Wet."
It's "D-O Wet,"
and it's everything the
character likes doing while wet.
And so you can imagine
the explicit lyrics
that come with all of that.
-Yeah, I can. Yeah, I can.
-And my vocal coach,
Fiora Cutler --
she is just the
sweetest person in the world.
And, so, just,
you know, imagining me
earnestly trying to sing those
graphic lyrics to her,
we were both
very, very embarrassed for me.
But we have now gotten to
the point where
we have recorded four songs and
we have a full E.P. coming out.
And we shot
a music video, as well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, gosh.
Okay. Look for --
Is "X Marks"
the first one coming up?
-Oh, "X Marks the G-Spot."
Yeah, that's the hit single,
I think,
but we got "Do Wet."
We got "I'mma Live Forever"
and we got "Just Like You"...
-Alright, yeah.
-...yeah, coming out soon.
-Yeah, "Do Wet."
-Mm-hmm.
-I do want to give away
a spoiler, by the way.
But -- Well, I'm allowed to,
because we asked you before if
we could talk about this,
because your character,
supposedly, is in a --
was in a Hall & Oates biopic.
-Mm-hmm.
-And so they show a scene from
that -- scenes from that.
And it's you and Channing Tatum
as Hall & Oates.
-Yeah.
-Was --
[ Applause ]
People want to see this.
-Yeah.
-Apparently, what I heard
is that when you were doing it,
it just turned out to be
so much fun,
everything was working that
you wanted to kept shooting
and you almost recorded
like four hours of this bit.
-Yeah. So, on the page,
it was probably like maybe
three or four lines
back and forth,
and we ended up filming for
like three or four hours.
We just couldn't stop riffing
on Hall & Oates.
And, you know, there's probably
like a 30-minute cut out there
of me and Channing just kind of
going back and forth,
arguing about who gets to
have the mustache,
because you can't have
a two-man band and two 'staches.
You've got to pick one.
-That's correct. That's correct.
-Yeah. Everyone knows the rules.
-Oates is the guy.
Of course. Yeah, John Oates.
You brought us
an exclusive clip.
Here's Dave Franco and
Channing Tatum
as Hall & Oates
in "The Afterparty."
Take a look at this.
-Aah!
You see -- that -- that right
there is what we need.
-A broken record?
-No, a smash hit!
This city will
put you in its mouth,
bite you up, and spit you out.
It's a -- It's an eater of men.
♪♪
-Wait. What did you just say?
Grab your ax.
It's chart-breaking time!
-Let's break them charts.
Come on, let's see.
-Okay, you go high.
I'll go the same high.
-Okay.
-And a one and...
-Yeah. And that's how they
wrote "Maneater."
Of course, that's exactly how.
Dave Franco, everybody.
-Oh, yeah.
-"The Afterparty" premieres
this Friday on Apple TV+.
It is super-funny,
super-well-done.
Good to see you.
Best to Alison, buddy.